we've seen their rocket equation and
we've studied the example when there's
no external forces now let's consider an
example when the external force is not
zero well one of our examples is just a
rocket taking off in a gravitational
field and so when we want to focus on
the external forces let's draw our
rocket at time T and now consider what
are the force diagrams on this rocket
well we have a gravitational force mg so
we're going to choose J hat up so now
what is our rocket equation look like we
wrote the exhaust velocity as minus mu J
hat and so if we write this now as a
vector equation in the J hat component
we get minus mg we have the rate that
the rocket mass is changing and this is
in R we have this is remember DM dr/dt
is going to be negative so there's a
minus and over here we have another this
is u because U is minus u and finally we
have M rocket DV R DT now once again
we're going to try to integrate this is
actually equal and we're going to try to
integrate this equation to find a
solution for the velocity as a function
of time when all the fuel is burned so
what we do is we'll multiply through by
DT and we have minus DM R times u equals
M R DB r and this is mass of the rocket
and now let's divide through by mass of
the rocket so we have minus G DT minus
DM r / M R u equals DV our
and once again we can integrate this
equation from some initial time to some
final time I'll just denote that by I
initial and I final and what we see here
is we have minus G times T final minus T
initial because we're integrating with
respect to time here we're integrating
mass so that's minus mu natural log and
I'm going to write this as M our final
over M our initial and over here we have
be our final minus be our initial and
let's just remove that time T and so now
here is our rocket equation now what we
notice here is let's look at some rocket
taking off so suppose that at T initial
equals zero we have the special
condition that VR and you show equals
zero and M our initial equals the mass
of the rocket dry mass that's all that's
not counting the fuel plus the total
mass of the fuel and the final at t
final when the engine turns off we're
going to try to find this velocity at t
final and our condition for the final
mass is all the fuels been burned so
this is just the dry mass of the rocket
and so what we get is we get minus G T
final now I'm going to switch the sign
here so we have if I invert the log that
will give a minus sign and I have plus u
log of M R of D plus mass of the fuel
that's the initial mass of the rocket
divided by just the dry mass
and that's equal to VR at T final so one
of the interesting questions that you
might ask is how fast should you burn
the fuel and what will that have to do
with the final speed so we can see from
this expression that if you burn the
fuel for a very long period of time so T
final is big then this piece will
diminish the final velocity so if you
want the fastest speed after you burn
the fuel you want to burn the fuel so
that T final is as short as possible we
have the shortest burn time will give us
the largest velocity when all the fuel
has been burned